ja und wir machen weiter mit quarantäne
und masken pflicht das kennen wir ja
jetzt alle nur zu gut die rede ist jetzt
aber nicht von corona sondern von den
affen brocken macht uns jetzt also das
nächste virus den unbeschwerten sommer
kaputt kommt jetzt der affen pocken
lockdown immer mehr fälle von diesen
affen brocken werden nämlich jetzt
bekannt allein in berlin sind es schon
zwei menschen doch was ist das für eine
krankheit diese affen brocken
die affen brocken kommen nun auch
vermehrt nach deutschland bisher bekannt
ein fall in münchen zwei in berlin
insgesamt mehr als 100 fälle in 12
ländern und das innerhalb von nur zwei
wochen bei den affen pocken handle sich
um eine klassische schmierinfektion
übertragung durch körperflüssigkeiten
aber auch das gemeinsame nutzen von
bettwäsche oder das teilen von kleidung
häufig wechselnde sexualpartner und
ungeschützter sex sind weitere
risikofaktoren die symptome fieber kopf-
und muskelschmerzen und ein ausschlag
der oft im gesicht begeht scheint sich
zu bestätigen was die genomsequenzierung
gebracht hat dass es sich wohl um eine
variante handelt die auch einen milden
verlauf zeitig sicherheitshalber wurde
glaube ich auch ein medikament bestellt
das für die kranken helfen kann aber im
moment wird wohl nicht benötigt in
spanien könnte die gay parade das
sogenannte maspalomas festival auf gran
canaria zum infektions hotspot geworden
sein hier feierten vom 5 mai bis 15 bei
80.000 menschen die belgischen behörden
glauben dass ein fetisch festival in
antwerpen zum superstar geworden sein
könnte daher gilt jetzt wer infiziert
ist muss 21 tage in quarantäne
reiserückkehrern wird geraten bei
ungewöhnlichen hautausschlägen
unverzüglich einen arzt aufzusuchen
seit anfang mai wurden in mehreren
europäischen und nordamerikanischen
ländern dutzende verdachtsfälle und
bestätigte infektion mit affen pocken
gemeldet etwa in kanada frankreich den
usa und großbritannien die zahl in
spanien nachgewiesener fälle ist derweil
laut medienberichten auf über 30
gestiegen
anstecken kann sich jeder daher
befürchtet man in expertenkreisen dass
die infektion in den sommermonaten
zunehmen werden
doch was sagen die deutschen zu der
neuen krankheit macht ihnen das sorgen
wir sind auf die straßen berlins
gegangen und haben nachgefragt was
machen tatsächlich angst hatte wenig ein
volk ohne aber das würde ich wirklich
nicht bekommen wollen ich habe es erst
gestern ein sozial media gesehen aber
ich weiß nicht ob es in wirklichkeit so
was gibt denkt man da so ein crooner 2.0
irgendwie so weit würde ich denken weil
wir glaube ich so hoffe ich zumindest
ein bisschen draus gelernt haben
zumindest deutschland aber ich sag mal
wäre halt jetzt wie es weil wir durch
genug sorgen gerade auf der welt wenn du
jetzt noch was kommen würde das glaub
das ist können wir nicht gebrauchen es
mit immer krankheiten geben es gab
klagen und es gibt auch menschliche bis
samstag ein kernteam kannst sowieso
nichts dagegen tun ich halte mich
einfach von affen fern danke für die
warnung da ja wenn nicht jetzt am körper
denke ich mal
wurde ich mir schon erschrecken ich weiß
gar nicht was das richtig ist tik tok
ich habe bei tik tok gesehen dass es
nicht gefährlich sein soll also ist es
auch nicht gefährlich das ist einfach
nur eklig
ja wir sprechen jetzt mit bild reporter
peter wilke der uns zugeschaltet ist
hier aus der hauptstadt er steht vor der
senatsverwaltung für gesundheit peter
hier in berlin immerhin der ort in
deutschland mit den meisten fällen
bisher wie gehen die berliner damit um
denn ob ihrer in berlin gibt es
mittlerweile drei bestätigte affen
brocken die gesundheitssenatorin
berichte von berlin hat aber gleich am
wochenende ja entwarnt sie hat gesagt es
gebe keinen grund zur panik es gebe
grund zur vorsicht dass sie stehe im
engen austausch mit dem rk ii mit dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium und
natürlich mit der charité der berühmten
klinik großen klinik hier in berlin
wegen dieser drei fälle da bereitet man
sich also auf weitere fälle vor es wurde
auch davor gewarnt dass es zu weiteren
fällen kommen kann und das dauert eben
vor sich zu halten ist allerdings wurde
auch gesagt dass wenn man symptome hat
dass man sich schnellstmöglich zum arzt
begeben soll und da eben jetzt der erste
kleine knackpunkt dass man eine fpf p2
maske tragen soll und ja ob das wirklich
so wirksam ist das ist zweifelhaft denn
bisher ist bei affen brocken nicht
bekannt dass es dort er es ohne die
übertragenen faktoren sind sondern dass
es eher über schleimhäute
geht also nicht über alles ohne deswegen
ist ein fb2 maske das durchaus fr kraft
aber es ist eben noch nicht viel bekannt
über dieses neue virus außerdem hat ein
experte der charité auch hier in berlin
gleich bekannt gegeben dass man vor
allen dingen eine überproportionale
häufung der fälle bei männern und
insbesondere nach sexualkontakt unter
männern beobachten würde
das auch recherchiert peter wie es den
patienten hier in berlin geht was kannst
du uns darüber sagen
genau es gibt eben diese drei patienten
einer davon war eben zuvor auf gran
canaria bei diesem festival allen dreien
geht es den umständen entsprechend recht
gut alle sind zu hause in häuslicher
isolation also nicht auch in stationärer
behandlung im krankenhaus einer hat das
krankenhaus verlassen
erwarten aber in dem krankenhaus wegen
etwas anderem und da wurde eben dieses
diese virusinfektion festgestellt und
jetzt läuft eben die ermittlungen nach
weiteren kontakten um eben eine rasante
ausbreitung des virus es vorerst zu
verhindern vielen dank peter wilke für
diese ersten informationen hier aus der
hauptstadt und den patienten wünschen
wir natürlich eine gute besserung das
begrüßen wir bei uns den virologen klaus
stöhr schönen guten morgen man hört ffp
zwei maske quarantäne das klingt ja fast
so es geht alles wieder von vorne los
belgien drei wochen quarantäne für fälle
mit affen pocken müssen wir uns herrscht
wirklich sorgen machen
also sorgen nun muss man sich nicht
machen für die wissenschaftler ist
eigentlich eine gelegenheit wieder was
zu lernen für einige wenige der
unangenehme infektion das gute wenn es
überhaupt was gut ist daran gibt ist
dass die infektion sehr schwer
weiterzugeben ist also man muss sich da
schon richtig anstrengen man teilt
eigentlich die patienten einen riesigen
gruppen eins zwei und drei risikogruppe
1 ist jemand der tatsächlich kontakt hat
zu einem solcher klinischer erkrankten
personen also symptome hat die fiba hat
die kopfschmerzen mattigkeit amazon
abgeschlagen und gleichzeitig die offene
läsionen auf der haut wenn man zu diesen
offenen millionen kontakt hat und zu
seiner person angehört man zur
risikogruppe 1 und daher lohnt sich
vielleicht sogar eine impfung die man
dahinter her damals aufsetzt aber alle
anderen kontakt zum thematischen
personen ohne diesen direkten
hautkontakt mit offenen wunden das ist
richtig und gut 200 gibt es rege gruppe
3 die bilder die wir jetzt gerade sehen
das sind bilder von richtigen menschen
pocken von einem der letzten fälle die
festgestellt wurden das ist natürlich
eine dramatische infektion mit sehr
hohen schule stellen das ist ganz anders
bei den affen pocken ja wenig menschen
infizieren sich der effekt die infektion
ist sehr schwierig an den nächsten
weiter zu geben und die geht auch nicht
immer an deswegen laufen sich solche
erkrankungen auch dann aus und wir
werden in den nächsten tagen sehen dass
das alles ab das noch weniger fälle
auftreten europaweit sind das weniger
als 200 wie berichtet wurden also hier
kann man gar keine parallelen zur krone
infektion ziehen dass es auch in der
gewisse ordnung weil dadurch
beruhigen er störe sie haben es gerade
selbst schon angesprochen und auch der
bayerische gesundheitsminister hat schon
über impfstoffe gesprochen er will diese
vorbestellen halten sie das denn jetzt
schon für sinnvoll und sollten wir uns
jetzt schon impfen lassen also sie und
ich sollte sich nie gehen lassen dass
wir uns infizieren es ist wahrscheinlich
genauso wahrscheinlich dass wir im lotto
gewinnen oder vom blitz erschlagen
werden die impfstoffe könnten aber den
ergeben 1000 dosen hätte in deutschland
da könnte man die für personen
bevorraten die dann kontakt hätten mit
solchen klinischen erkrankten die drei
personen die es in deutschland gibt die
mussten behandelt werden ärzte
schwestern die sich auch exponieren
unter umständen die vielleicht nicht
gleich von anfang an die richtige
kleidung tragen und da kann man über
solche impfung nachdenken das ist doch
ein ganz kleiner patientenkreis der
impfstoff besteht aus der verfügung die
engländer haben auch jetzt einen kleinen
vorrat angelegt hier geht es auf keinen
fall darum die gesamte population zu
impfen da würde auch gar keinen
impfstoff zur verfügung steht ist auch
absolut und nicht notwendig ganz andere
erkrankungen ganz andere bekämpfung ganz
andere weitergabe des erregers ganz
anderes risiko ganz andere notwendigkeit
auch zu reagieren
wissenschaftlich interessant für die
behörden wichtig solche infektionen auch
sich anzuschauen weil man immer
natürlich befürchten kann das wieder die
normalen menschen brocken auftreten da
möchte man relativ schnell reagieren die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist war auch extrem
gering die menschen proben wurden
ausgerottet gibt aber an einigen labor
natürlich noch die viren sie braucht man
uns wieder impfstoff herzustellen
falls doch was passiert so wie jetzt mit
dem affen brocken oder tatsächlich
nochmals punkten ihr und auftaucht aber
wie gesagt gesundheitsbehörden wissen
bescheid wissen das gesundheitswesen
muss bereit sein aber für uns alle wer
ist der jackpot der negative jackpot
weiter und zitieren naja dann wirklich
lieber im lotto gewinnen wenn da die
chance geben so hoch sind sehr vielen
herzlichen dank für ihre einschätzungen